kalorien
[Musik]
man gibt ein flop
die kombinierten
wir zeigen euch was die eine woche
ein geheimtipp
berlin
sie sparen
[Musik]
wir wollen in den vordergrund der
arabische berlin plc mit dabei
[Musik]
wer kennt nach den herzhaften immer
irgendetwas süßes mag es wenn ihr noch
hinten auf der istiklal straße ist dafür
direkt am tag unterwegs ist eigentlich
aus war aber wir wollen ja besondere
finden hier haben wir obst und drucken
hat mich total angelockt wird so im
prinzip nur geschnittenes obst
die bohne
landete
wieder kommt der geschmack denn unser
erstes unsere schießt in der türkei bzw
für dieses mal
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
er dürfte mit dem chemiker seine volle
kanne vanille fehlt okay da darf man
nicht sparen er warne darf man nicht
sparen gar keine gründe dem markt keine
zukunft
tatsächlich konnte speisefischen so
einfach wie es geht nicht also vanille
es gibt es ausschaut
minute weniger im backofen werden wir
kunden sind noch nicht
wie genau also
also
wir sind jetzt die partie und hier kann
man so gut frühstücken hier gibt es
mehrere fisches cafés an einem fahrrad
zu füßen
wir gehen bis zu bis zu acht siebenmeter
das maximum was schönsten seite ein auto
fahren und wir gehen jetzt hier auf
jeden fall über den dächern istanbuls
frühstücken und dann in istanbul
einfach mal auf einer dachterrasse
frühstücken mit einem hammer
ausschließen folge wurden
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt bei espresso lab und
haben uns diesen bongos zu bestimmen
einen ganzen stadtteil mit ganz viel
schokolade bildung ist doch mal war auch
der teig ist oder nicht habe und ich
weiß wie die schokolade fließt richtig
laufen gesehen ein mandarinen macarons
auf die hand mal gucken wie der schmeckt
schon dafür fallen
das sei technisch und die haben wir es
dazu im zitrone ob es das ist typisch
türkisch
new york
so richtige klasse keiner tat ist die
kumpel diesen katalog mit gemütlichen
dann natürlich albers das ist einmal nur
ein tod mit zuzog und käse
tomaten paprika und berger ist die nasa
burger
den habe ich mir vorstellen mich problem
ersten mal
schmecken bisher
walter burger wohl irgendwas in zu
beraten schief gelaufen
doch wenn man nur geil
kostet nur einen euro gerechnet
vielleicht deswegen
[Musik]
jetzt schickt ihn nicht kennst
aber das ist arabische knöpfe dass sich
die typische abgerückt
ja ich manchmal findet man die
leckersten sachen an so kleinen ecken
mit number st
naja
egal
nicht so süß obwohl er zu kassieren
darauf kommt nicht zu süß
markus aber gemacht richtig lecker und
nichts zu essen
normalerweise holt einkehrte wer immer
wichtig um
gar nicht gut hier gibt es mitten in der
türkei ein deutscher songs brezel augen
stange haben wir sind daher typische
food trends also geht es weiter in die
richtung
[Musik]
es gebe etwas frühstücken wir sind ein
bisschen weit gelaufen ihr müsst auch
weit laufen wenn ihr gut frühstücken
wollte ich zeige euch das nicht hilft
[Musik]
die speisekarte wird das frische
direkter wird und zu bestellen einzige
was machen könntest nachbestellen wenn
man was wiederum vor allem angegeben
ganz komisch oder geschlossen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
circa eine halbe stunde im taxi gefahren
und sind echt in seiner ich glaube dass
die rechts- und studenten gingen aber
wohl eine sehr coole ecke und wir sind
hier vom emilia kaffee braucht ganz süße
desserts aber was besonders findet es
aussehen ist kaffee ist immer eine
chance
[Musik]
wir haben hier einen ballon der gefüllt
ist mit 1 15 uhr und da haben wir einen
wurde kuchen statt
mit
so spaßig mcqueen so schlecht wie es auf
ihn ankommt
wie man sich und bei der emilia
cheesecake was ich echt noch sagen
wollte hier sieht man die verbrannte
oberfläche das habe ich jetzt bei den
anderen cafés nicht gesehen und es zeigt
mir dass da die richtige back temperatur
eingestellt wurde ist mein anspruch
mit plakaten sehr kritisch zum bis der
mann ist auf jeden fall sein wird ich
mach's werden beim könnte was den trick
der vanille geschmack überragen das
macht ein guter auftakt in die tiefe
auch ein bisschen mehr sein dürfen
ansonsten sendung sehr sehr lecker
welchen weg ich habe
[Musik]
ja
den schlagabtausch in butter gebraten
und versuchen wir das auch in polen hat
das volkswagen zu stellen und heute
der euro bund bestellt und jetzt
[Musik]
ich muss sagen im falschen mutter immer
noch sehr dass mond hätte man sich
sparen bevölkerung sehr lecker wir haben
uns arrangiert reports die zweigeteilt
ist echt ausreichen
danach können wir noch einen kleinen
sagen immer stärker machen ich bin echt
gespannt wie der muster burger schmecken
ich hab ja haben zu heroes bürger
angehen ist angespannt also das ist
helfen der luckenberger sondern dass man
wirklich nur reden aber behaupten dass
das etwas zu gewollt hat ist es
wahrscheinlich dass diese feiner
schmecken einfach keinen geschmack von
an geschmack
endlich wird am liebsten noch nach
gewalt und noch gar nicht weißenberger
sonst eigentlich nur sein kann aber
trotzdem finden
diese fein gewürzt sind die man die man
einfach ist und so vielleicht kein
bürger damit glücklich
[Musik]
sollte auf jeden fall einmal gemacht ist
für das ganze land
die wahlweise auf hessischen schafskäse
kartoffeln und fleisch mega lecker und
mega thema geworden
genau das machen seine älteren frauen
optischen so richtig traditionellen
[Musik]
einmal dann geld und schmuck
manchmal hat man okay dann essen wir
keinen schlecker also zu krähen sachen
und sowas ist bestellt war überhaupt
nicht erkannt dass man crêpes gefüllt
mit mit gemüse und dann waren sozusagen
suchen inneren finde ich kann man nicht
essen kann die tour durch meine kindheit
immer das fleisch und gemüse damit
machte lief falsch was eben bei katzen
leben aber in essen könnten desserts und
kuchen richtig kunden mit beschäftigt
[Musik]
ach es ist ein warmer schokolade mit
schubkarren umhüllt in einer schublade
und das ganze wurde dann offenbar
schokosoße damit sich die kugel ist so
geschickt einfach perfekt millionen
kalorien genau okay dass mein bruder und
ich hab den san sebastian schießen und
optimiert
[Musik]
neben anderen laden
mit war alles besser
[Musik]
der asiatischen seite direkt am meer
findet ihr viele sehr kräfte da gibt's
sehr leckere kräfte unter gemessen und
er war schon bisher
das ist der berg schwarzen dienstag
gewesen
mosaik kuchen sehr bekannt bei den
türken einfach nur schokolade mit keksen
wenn der türkei sollte auf jeden fall
die türkischen unsere das ist doch was
für alle die den hunger zwischendurch
[Musik]
und natürlich muss in die linsensuppe
auch immer ein bisschen zitrone das fast
so gut zusammen und hier haben wir noch
so ein bisschen was er dessen würdig es
geht ihr blick in tausend verschiedene
varianten sie sind beide in höhenhaus
gebacken aber dass die panierten
varianten möchte geht entweder im auge
war ich mich empfehlen definitiv weil
wir schon schon beim 17
von daher von daher irgendwann die
aussicht ist auch wichtig und weisen mit
guter ausbildung
[Musik]
das heißt frittierte türkische mini
maultaschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]